alors des mois qu'on aurait dû lever et
arrêter tout ce cirque mais bon alors
pour toi saint cyr parce que on le voit
il ya plein de gens qui me posent la
question en ce moment je te jure et
laurent je te jure aujourd'hui il ya
peut-être une dizaine de personnes qui
m'ont dit tous les autres pays et même
la france d'ailleurs on va dire allez
sortez tout ça y est terminée à sion est
ce qu'on a vécu une mascarade pendant
trois ans oui à l'eau mais sans rigoler
ça fait 2 ans 1 ben moi ça fait trois
ans j'ai toujours en avance ben non
c'est suffisant on va pas bouder on va
pas bouder notre plaisir c'est sûr ça va
mieux c'est en train de s'arranger non
mais est ce que est ce qu'il y aurait à
nous libérer par petits bouts oui mais
la reine des neiges société du nom mais
laurent je te jure ya plein de gens qui
me disent mes envies qu'on n'aurait pas
pu faire ça dès le début laisser sortir
tout le monde terminée il n'y a pas de
tout faire quelqu'un
les pays le fonds propres le fond
progressivement mouais moi je vis à
bruxelles en belgique on a les mêmes
restrictions on a les mêmes restrictions
en allemagne les restrictions sont
toujours la suisse va l'élever dans
quelques semaines serait jo seule
angleterre viennent les lgv est donc
globalement la france va lever petit à
petit les restrictions dans trois mois
on est libéré alors juste un peu les
nommés par nos biens experts un pays
dans le monde qui a dit dès le début de
yann et voilà il ya deux eaux qui a dit
nous on s'en fout sortez tous et qu'est
ce qui s'est passé non j'ai envie de
savoir ça si on dirait qu'il a fait par
les pays sous développés à part les pays
sous développés il ya peu de pays qui
ont laissé mourir tous les vieux sans
réagir d'accord donc pour toi c'est vrai
quelqu'un non mais je te pose la
question moi je pense que si tous les
pays du monde rit la même stratégie n
raison c'est parce que il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'endroits où on était prêt à
accepter des cinq états unis et c'est
comme en classe il ya le premier de la
classe qui le fait donc les états unis
font tout mais je suis derrière non mais
tu n'as mai souviens toi que homo début
de l'épidémie il y avait tellement de
morts à new york il a fallut en urgence
tout bloquer faire venir un bateau
militaire chirurgical et médical pour
soigner les gens à new york parce que
tous les hôpitaux de new york était
saturé il faut pas oublié ce qu'était la
situation et j'ai calculé catastrophe
est sûre est ce que vous êtes d'accord
vous êtes d'accord avec pierre non mais
sans rire toi souviens-toi n'y en a eu
d'accord que là en fait on est
typiquement serre que si on raisonne
comme il ya deux ans moi je suis
d'accord il ya deux ans on découvrait
cette mallette il ya eu un confinement
moi j'étais plutôt pour ce continent
parce qu'on ne savait pas ce qui nous
arrive est envoyé des images de show
n'est pas mon fils aurait rien dit plus
tôt ou tard peut-être dans une sorte
d'équilibré à mais non maintenant ça a
changé maintenant
un vaccin maintenant on recule cette
épidémie on voit que cette épidémie
c'est pas la peste noire contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a voulu nous dire et julia
quelque chose de très paradoxale dedans
dans ce sujet c'est à dire que on nous
parle de l'allègement des restrictions
alors que ce n'est vous il ya dix jours
un pass vaccinale est entrée en vigueur
en france je veux dire la première
mesure à alléger c'est quand même le
pass d'accidents après supprimer ça tout
de suite après ça vous paraît pas
bizarre ici ta région tes envies ou tes
bons et pilaf cascada non mais la france
a quand même et je suis désolé mais la
france a quand même été là l'un des pays
les plus liberticides sur certains sur
cette histoire donc et picotte quand le
docteur alexandre dit on ne doit pas
laisser les on a on a on ne pouvait pas
laisser les vieux mourir mourir je
trouve ça un peu délicat quand on sait
dans quel état était l'hôpital est ce
qu'on a fait des vieilles personnes dans
les ehpad qui avait le coded non
aujourd'hui on va ressasser le passé
compte et non le passé maintenant pour
un parti drame de son seul talent était
là on est en train de fumer libellé
meute les mesures liberticides petit
tapis de cécile pas ça sa prise va aller
mieux dans le rang avec 6 sur les
passions n'ai pas accès à ce type
d'accidents yvette n'ont pas supprimé
mais il va être levé dans quelques
semaines quand les réalisations seront
vidés donc globalement des ça va mieux
et on est c'est quoi la défense relevé
et
supprimera les gagnants xavi 6 mois qui
arrivent dans mes annoncé ce qui va
alors on le remet cela je crois qu'ils
ont un invariant et moi je vais vous
dire une chose
et qu'à mon avis tous les hivers enfin
moi le jeu je ne souhaite pas ça mais
j'ai très peur que maintenant on entend
dans une société où du mois ce que
darien il va revenir mais les donnera
donc la héros mais revenons au micro
remontant jusqu'à février
on aura quelques mois quatre mois
pendant lesquels il ya une partie
population qui vivra en un jeu qui sera
isolé socialement alors que la majorité
du pays peut se faire vacciner donc
faites vous vacciner mais arrêtez
d'emmerder les noms n'ont pu y aller
mais l'autre ce que je veux dire
sa mère dina le vaccin est imposé au
pourquoi l'imposer aux autres et c'est
la première restriction que je vois
évidemment on a les masques le climat
anxiogène mais c'est ce pass vaccinale
enfin il ya cinq six millions de
personnes qui vivent en marge de la
société on parle d'un allègement des
restrictions au danemark ils ont
supprimé le pass sanitaire vient pas de
passes vaccinés avec un programme
vaccinal il faut supprimer maintenant et
les enfants toujours le masque à l'école
aux siens nature à londres et au delà du
fait que c'est insupportable qu'on a
encore des restrictions au bout de deux
ans ce qui est terrible c'est qu'ils
sont complètement absurde ccc mentionné
pardon mais qu'est ce que ça change de
manger debout ou assis dans un bar ça
change quand vous entrez dans un
restaurant que vous marchiez 3 mars avec
un masque car vous avez enlevé pendant
une heure après le pire m'a lancé dans
les avions que c'est ce qu'ils nous
disent oui vous pouvez manger mais entre
chaque bouchée faut remettre un peu déçu
mais ça n'a rien à envier celle
ci aux états unis ça nous fait paris new
york voilà ils vous disent manger mais
entre chaque bouchée vont remonter votre
masque ça n'a aucun des actionnaires
parce que moi je n'aurais pas compris et
vous le dis en anglais ça parce qu'il
les respecte
mais voilà donc ces app store une
boutique
mais tout ça n'a aucun sens franchement
c'est ce qui est intéressant est
intéressant ce que vous dites c'est que
regarder ça fait effectivement six mois
avec le kazakh signale pas sanitaires
toutes les mesures qu'on a mis en place
le masque les gèle tous ces annonces
anxiogènes sépare et hop us une partie
de la population l'isolant socialement
et pourtant aujourd'hui là on a 400
mille cas il ya ces pains en un an on
avait vingt mille cas 20 fois plus de
cas et on a 90 % impulsion et j vacciner
à quel moment va ouvrir les yeux à quel
membre a considéré que cette obligation
vaccinale on disait que c'était pour
souvenez vous vacciner pour protéger les
autres mais vous foutez de notre gueule
regardez le graphique